les chefs d'État africain se rendraient
donc à Moscou mais aussi bien sûr à Kiev
Cyril ramaosa expliqué qu'il avait
téléphoné personnellement tant au
président Poutine qu'au président
zellenski il a également déclaré avoir
prévenu le secrétaire général de l'ONU
Antonio Guti reste qui salue cette
initiative donc une médiation qui ferait
presque oublié le fiasco diplomatique
des derniers jours vous savez Pretoria
était accusé d'avoir vendu des armes à
Moscou des accusations qui venaient de
l'ambassadeur américain après Toria un
ambassadeur qui a dû d'ailleurs se
rétracter car l'Afrique du Sud dément en
bloc ses accusations une enquête en tout
cas a été ouverte pour faire la lumière
sur ses ventes d'armes mais cette
fameuse médiation va permettre peut-être
à l'Afrique du Sud de prouver sa
neutralité